is there a meaning to life that we can
take from this
from this brief
emergence of complexity that arises from
simple things and then goes into uh a
heat death that is once again returns to
simple things as the march of the second
law the thermodynamics goes on i think
there is but i don't think it's a
universal answer
and so i think throughout
the ages there has been
a kind of quest for
some
final way of articulating meaning and
purpose whether it's god
whether it's love whether it's
companionship i mean many people put
forward different ways of taking this
question on
and there is no one right answer when
you recognize deeply
that the universe doesn't care there is
nothing out there
that is the final answer it's not as
though we need a more powerful telescope
and somehow if we can look deeply into
the universe all will become clear in
fact the deeper we've looked both
literally and metaphorically
into the universe and into the structure
of reality the more it's become clear
that
we are just a momentary byproduct of
laws of physics
that don't have any emotional
content they don't have any intrinsic
sense of meaning or purpose
and when you recognize that you realize
that searching for the universal for
this kind of
a question is a fool's errand every
individual has the capacity to make
their own meaning to set their own
purpose and that's not some platitude
that is what we are
because there is no fundamental answer
it's what you make of it and however
much that may sound like a hallmark card
this really is the deep lesson
of physics and science more generally
over the past few hundred years well
there's some level where you can
objectively say
that whatever we've got going on here is
kind of peculiar it's kind of um
special in in in in terms of complexity
and maybe you can even begin
to measure it and like come up with
metrics where whatever we got going on
on earth these like uh
interesting hierarchical complexities
that form more and more sophisticated
biological system that seems kind of
unique when you look at the entire
universe
you